[Música]
una historia de una mujer de una niña y
voy a ir pasando poco a poco cómo fueron
los retos de esa niña que se convirtió
en mujer y que poco a poco fue pasando
de momento tras momento y sobre todo el
mundo del mercado laboral y de otras
situaciones que la llevaron a
convertirse en una persona diferente y
que tiene que devolverle a la vida lo
que le ha regalado y que quizás este
mensaje pueda identificar a mujeres ya
hombres que están hoy día acompañándome
y que están aquí escuchando en las redes
nos están escuchando
esta es una niña
que viene de una ciudad intermedia casi
olvidada casi de un sector rural
hermanita de cuatro hermanos hombres de
un papá y una mamá muy espirituales
donde la ausencia del papá casi siempre
estaba presente porque tenía que
trabajar era un profesor de física y
matemáticas
laboraba en un sector rural su mamá era
ama de casa y cuidaba a sus hermanitos y
todo esto era un mundo como divertido
hermoso tuvo una niñez muy feliz entre
arbolitos pajaritos amiguitos crece una
niña con muchas ganas de vivir en una en
un colegio de monjas donde le enseñaban
a coser le enseñaba la parte académica
le enseñaban los valores y le enseñaban
la humildad
esta niña creía que todo era así juego
amor todo transcurría y empieza a
convertirse en una adolescente muy
bonita
y pues creía en esos cuentos le
encantaban los cuentos de princesas
y el príncipe azul de walt disney que
nos han vendido pues siempre este tema y
si señores como era la niña empezó a
volverse como bonita tenía pretendientes
en el colegio sus amiguitos todos se
enamoran
teniendo 14 casi 15 años
la adolescencia se enamoró de un chico
más grande que está con más experiencia
un chico de un estrato social mucho más
alto que está donde la enamora y como a
quizás a algunas adolescentes les ha
pasado le piden la prueba de amor pero
no era en esta niña el tema físico el
gusto de estar con un hombre sino las
ganas de sentirse amada y los sueños y
las realidades y quizás en este colegio
en esa escuelita no le enseñaban antes
nueva internet ahora tenemos internet
whatsapp nos hablamos con las amigas
todo en este momento nada de eso
esta niña de novia se enamora a la
prueba de amor y a los pocos meses no
entiende lo que está pasando
después sí señor la niña estaba
embarazada
yo sé que han de tener casos así de 15
años esta niña ya estaba embarazada de
su primer hijo
y empieza una historia fuerte porque ese
mundo de corazones pajaritos se
transforma y se convierte en una
realidad diferente
aunque viene con una ilusión viene con
unos aspectos que marcan mucho la vida
una tarde a la niña una señora llegó en
un carro muy elegante se la llevó y le
dijo que tenía que irse con ella y el
muchachito era el actual novio y la
llevaron a un consultorio oscuro raro
hablaban entre todos y tal fecha
programaban un aborto
esa niña en medio de que tenía tanta
ingenuidad
dijeron es que vamos a la vida no se
puede parar aquí hay que abortar tú no
puedes tener a este muchachito que
sinceramente en ese momento no primaba
sino el peladito hijo de eta pero la
niña y ese bebé que venía en camino no
eran importantes
con los valores que le habían dado sus
papás porque le da mucha biblia entendió
que la vida no podía ser cortada y bien
solo en su responsabilidad y en sus
ingenuidades y de tener ese bebé y no
aceptó
llevar a cabo ese proceso y se enfrentó
una vida diferente y empieza he aquí una
vida marcada con desilusiones porque
esta gente se la llevó porque
económicamente esta niña no contaba con
los recursos para traer ese muchachito a
la casa donde sus hermanitos le
arrancaron de su hogar y se la llevaron
a vivir a donde otra familia muy
diferente a la que ella era donde el
muchachito caprichoso era infiel
era grosero era un patán
así pasó la vida y ya y descubrió que
tenía que salir adelante que no iba a
regresar a ser una carga para sus padres
sino que debía trabajar y debía estudiar
pasaron los años y ella inicia su vida
a tratar de emprender pero aquí nos
encontramos una barrera que a nivel
mundial es penalizada la penalización de
la maternidad y el cuidado no remunerado
el sector productivo ha marcado muy
fuertemente a las mamitas que tenemos
hijos menores de 6 años porque no somos
muy atractivas en las empresas
cuando ella hizo sus procesos para
tratar de buscar empleo a nadie le daba
trabajo
le preguntaban y tienes hijos que los va
a cuidar y tal pues porque la
responsabilidad le competían a ella
entonces entra en ese momento en esa
necesidad de avanzar de querer salir
adelante y pues el único camino para
poder estudiar y tomar ingresos
adicionales de la informalidad
porque propició en la casa cuidar bebés
trabajar y más encima con una pareja muy
machista que veía en esta niña
con esta jovencita esta mujer tal vez
vio el potencial pero no quería que lo
desarrolle porque sabía que iba a partir
entonces lee el mecanismo era encerrarla
decirle que no podía que no era capaz y
por eso el mensaje a muchas mujeres es
quizás están en este momento
ustedes son poderosas en un potencial
muy grande no crean las voces de sus
parejas mal sanas sino que crean en el
poder que tienen usted
en este momento esta muchachita que se
enfrenta al desempleo a la realidad que
vivimos día a día entra la informalidad
no había otro camino también esta niña
aprendió
en temas de emprendimiento a sacar
adelante a ganarse sus ingresos con
mucho esfuerzo mientras estudia a los
chicos a salir adelante también conoce
muy bien qué es el emprendimiento pero
también conoce muy bien este tema de la
informalidad y aquí en cali sí que
tenemos ellos según cifras del nor med
es el observatorio de mercado laboral
aquí en la región nos dice que el 46 por
ciento en cali trabaja en la
informalidad sus recursos provienen de
ese sector y donde el desempleo en las
mujeres jóvenes se encuentran está entre
el 24% versus el 14% de los hombres
la desigualdad es grande las mujeres
tenemos
un reto mucho más grande para poder
salir adelante
sí señores hay un componente muy fuerte
que ya sabía que tenía que romper debía
de educarse tenía que estudiar pero con
esas adversidades ser mamá un tipo
machista no apoyo económico o sea el
panorama era terrible
pero esta niña dijo hay una gran apuesta
que es la educación como sea tenía que
estudiar y en medio de su informalidad
de ganarse los ingresos conoce gente
valiosa porque siempre en estos caminos
de la vida encontramos personas valiosas
ángeles de llamado
una persona que está la conoció hijo que
chica espí la lista oye le pregunta a
esta niña esta jovencita ya mamá quieres
estudiar
te interesaría una beca en un instituto
técnico y señores no había una
universidad como esta será un instituto
donde las personas se ganan la vida para
poder estudiar y donde de verdad se
valora el estudio ahí es cuando empieza
una carrera técnica profesional y que
posteriormente con mucho esfuerzo
termina su profesionalización esta niña
jovencita cada vez más audaz que va
conociendo el mundo y una realidad
porque el conocimiento y la educación
nos lleva a retarnos nos lleva a salir
adelante nos lleva a pensar diferente
cada vez veía más cruel la realidad que
estaba viviendo su relación era terrible
en ello decide tomar la decisión de
separarse de esa relación
y pues señores lastimosamente
era un tema muy complicado en el que
llevaba pues esa esos dramas emocionales
de su hogar y más encima empieza una una
una entrada al sector público sí señores
después de que estudio y todo eso se
ganó una convocatoria y entra esta chica
a trabajar al sector público y vaya
sorpresa se encontró con el dichoso
contrato de prestación de servicios este
contrato de prestación de servicios
que más de uno debe estar aquí lo conoce
muy bien en el que le hacen cumplir
horario en el que un jefe le da órdenes
a un le ponen la camiseta institucional
pero ahí está ese contra tico donde no
es bien usado porque es un instrumento
pero no debe cumplir horarios ni debe
estar asumido esta manera ahí ella entra
pero también tiene una cosa bien
complicada es una de las barreras que
sufrimos las mujeres el acoso laboral
esta chica como ya estaba como preparada
está bonita el jefe como que estaba muy
entusiasmado
la chica quería seguir adelante y o
entrar a otro puesto por sus capacidades
del señor y no le daba la pruebita venga
al acoso tenga vuelve a ser mi amante
tengamos una relación extra para darle
ese puesto de un trabajo formal el señor
ha hecho la chica tuvo que retirarse
y seguir avanzando en la vida en esos
trabajos que todas las mujeres lo que
alguna vez hemos pasado y hemos vivido
ese placer
pues señores más encima estando en ese
trayecto decide romper esa relación
empieza una nueva vida
se va a la casa de sus padres ya
legalizada está digamos que esa
situación malsana emprenden en su etapa
emocional otro momento después de
maltratos humillaciones detenciones de
que pueda salir adelante y pues señores
como les parece
tuvo un atentado un atentado para
cortarle la vida porque esa persona no
tenía que vivir si no era de esa otra
persona o no tenía que salir adelante y
tenía que la única manera porque no la
de tenía ninguna fuerza era cortarle la
vida señores esta muchacha estuvo
involucrada en un atentado en el que la
llevó a tener que huir como los
migrantes venezolanos que a veces yo
conozco invite a una persona muy
especial que la veía con sus bebitos muy
apenada por querer salir adelante sí así
es como algunas que las personas nos
están marcado la vida con un atentado o
con quererle la vida por ser mujer por
tomar decisiones por tomar una voz
si le pasó a esa muchacha
[Música]
qué pasa
les voy a contar que esta muchachita soy
yo maria cristina ruiz
la vida la llevo estos minutos no me dan
para seguirles detallando tanto pero la
vida le cambió y llega en un momento a
conocer por medio de personas que les
digo que son ángeles
personas como tan valiosas en el amor
porque también conocí a un hombre
maravilloso que le impulso
conoció también unas personas que
creyeron en su potencial hizo un proceso
y empezó a trabajar para la organización
internacional del trabajo cuando estoy
aquí me pregunto bueno dios tenía que
pasar por todos los episodios de la vida
desde que era un adolescente para
conocer las brechas que sufrimos las
mujeres
desde adolescentes para ingresar al
mundo laboral tenía que estar el hoy
para conocer técnicamente los 12
convenios que desde 1919 después de la
primera guerra mundial donde más de 40
millones de personas pierden la vida
porque tuvieron que los hombres irse a
la guerra y donde solamente quedan las
mujeres y los niños y la fuerza laboral
es reemplazada de los hombres a las
mujeres
en 1919 estaban las mujeres liderando el
mercado laboral
y ahí es cuando nace esta organización a
petición de las mujeres a petición de
los jóvenes porque porque eran no habían
derechos habían muchas mujeres que
habían muerto en esa época encerradas en
una fábrica habían muchas cosas
aberrantes en contra de los trabajadores
y así la organización internacional del
trabajo por petición de el mundo de la
necesidad nace y es actualmente donde se
está
desarrollando diferentes convenios y
donde se media a los gobiernos ya los
diferentes países para que puedan hacer
valer estos derechos fundamentales de
las personas
señores
y sobre todo mujeres
ustedes tienen el poder tenemos
mecanismos tenemos convenios podrán el
gobierno los países que están en proceso
de desarrollar todas todas estas
dinámicas para protección de la mujer
para desarrollar mecanismos que nos
puedan llevar a que la igualdad de
género pueda ser algo que no demore 209
años como lo dice él hoy te necesitamos
a este paso 209 años para que la
igualdad de género para que la la
remuneración del trabajo del cuidado sea
un hecho
vamos a esperar 209 años mujeres hombres
yo los invito a la reflexión los invito
sobre todo a las mujeres porque tenemos
ese poder de ser esas cabezas en los
hogares de que las mujeres les enseñemos
a nuestros hijos a no discriminar
a no maltratar a nuestras hijas a no
dejarse maltratar
s de nosotras elevaron la voz desde
nosotras depende de nosotras
que podamos mujeres no permitir el acoso
laboral no permitir que la prestación de
servicios sobre todo en estas épocas
cobre la cuenta de cobro de aquellos que
tienen el poder para darles un contrato
y tenga que dar la pruebita a todo el
tiempo cuando se vaya a firmar ese
contrato es de nosotras mujeres es de
nosotros señores la reflexión a los
hombres nosotras necesitamos trabajar
necesitamos ser productivas necesitamos
ser esas mamás que sacan adelante a
nuestros hijos
necesitamos no ser una competencia
hombres y mujeres nosotros necesitamos
complementar complementarnos
hombres y mujeres para que podamos sacar
adelante una igualdad en el mundo una
igualdad en el mercado laboral una
igualdad en el planeta podamos sostener
nuestro planeta porque nuestro planeta
se está acabando y esa fuerza que es la
resiliencia que es el poder que tienen
hombres y mujeres para salir de las
adversidades para salir de los momentos
difíciles todos tenemos es
aquí estoy la aún hoy te me contrato
vengo trabajando y siento el dolor
porque me tocó vivirlo porque lo he
vivido y por eso siento pasión al hacer
esto y le devuelvo a la vida solamente
ese mensaje tenemos el poder nosotros y
necesitamos del gobierno y necesitamos
de todos esos actores para que las
mujeres podamos ser empoderadas pero
ante nada ante ellos nosotras
necesitamos creerlo
esa es mi invitación creamos los sepamos
quiénes somos y a dónde podemos llegar
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]